[Music]
i don't think i've ever worked a day in
my life because i love
what i do if you have to think about
something too long
it's probably something you shouldn't be
doing don't quit
hey there he is what's up man
how you doing jake i'm doing great buddy
we've got
a legend in the house ladies and
gentlemen if you don't know
body by jake uh has been what the
pioneer
in the the personal training fitness
space
you've been doing this for how long when
was your first like when did you first
become
a public figure would you say well man
you know i was the first guy to do
personal fitness training and made it an
occupation in
is when 19 1980s man uh i was uh i was
18 years old
and uh i had this i had this dream to
become mr america
and uh uh i was the first one in my
family by the way to
i'm the oldest of four uh first one to
ever go to college
uh i went to college upstate new york
you know the
it's called cornell university you know
cornell
i went to cortland down the street okay
and
uh we're we're great school great
division three school
but uh you know uh
it's not too conducive to walk around in
your gold lame posing trunks in 18
inches of snow
and uh it was one of those moments i'm a
big believer in life is about moments
and uh my mom used to check in
every day at college just to see how i
was doing and i've always had this
and i know you talk a lot about dreams
and passion and all this great stuff
like that
and to me i'm a big believer as i said
life is about moments and everybody has
a dream there's so many folks who are
watching and listening right now
you know who have dreams and and
and find this true and kind of
disseminate the way you want but
you know it's always the people seems to
be closest to you
are the ones that seem to be
negative if that's the right word i'm
going to use right now because let me
give you the case in point
so i get up the courage enough to tell
my mom
instead of talking about poli-sci or
english i said ma
i'm going to go to california to become
a bodybuilder and there was silence on
the phone and all of a sudden
i hear herbie my dad's name pick up the
phone and talk to your kid i'm putting
my head in the oven
and all of a sudden all right the the
bus ride
from upstate new york to baldwin long
island
felt like i was going from from from la
to australia it was that long
and i remember my father telling me
listen you want to go to california get
it out of your system
i had a girlfriend who told me you're
never gonna you're never gonna amount to
anything you're not
you're you're a fat guy you're not gonna
be mr america
and my friends all said the same thing
and i made the trick
i got here summer 1977 when i still said
when the dinosaurs still roamed the
earth
arnold schwarzenegger lou ferrigno all
the big bodybuilders all the guys that
i had the magazines came to life and i
entered the mr southern california
contest right
we all have dreams we all have passions
and pursuits mine was a single
singular focused mr america and that's
the name of the deal
i entered the mr southern california
contest right
i come in second place the guy that
beats me
is on steroids now wait a second i read
all the muscle magazines
everybody said eat 18 eggs and 24
chickens a day
and you two could become mr america i
clucked a lot evan but you know what it
never happened for me but nobody ever
mentioned
steroids now let me tell you we talked
the truth because i think like in
anything in my life now i'm 62 years old
i've always been a believer in emotional
straight shooter
talk right to people everything i've
done in my career
i look right at people's eyes and i
think you know the same thing too
you could tell if somebody's doing a
routine on you by just looking at their
eyes
and i've and and i've been blessed in my
life with not the smartest guy on the
planet i was never a school
guy i was a street smart guy and i could
tell when somebody's doing a routine on
me
and for me my life was always about
okay i'm just gonna go straight ahead at
this thing so wait a second steroids
no one talked about steroids i'm 18
years old
i have my friends my girlfriend my
parents all saying you're gonna come
home
i had to make a decision i have four
kids today i'm married almost 32 years
my great wife tracy
i've been very blessed man uh i have a
daughter
and three sons ages from 28 to 19.
they're terrific um and
and i talk about i've always talked
about decision making
and i've always said to them as kids if
you have to think about something
too long it's probably something you
shouldn't be doing
and when it was that moment in my life
once again life's about moments and
sometimes there are great ones
and sometimes there are not so great
this was a moment where
i had to make a decision do i take the
steroids or not and the reason why i
didn't
was simple i was afraid i was afraid to
do it i remember in fourth and fifth
grade
the nurse would give you those tb tests
maybe for your time
and they and they they would just sort
of poke you right there
little progs i would faint
so forget about putting a needle in my
own batissimo if you know what i'm
saying right
and i made this decision i said i'm not
going to go back to new york
in my opinion a loser i'm going to stay
in l.a
because i love what working out did for
me i love how i felt when i was
exercising
it not only built my body but i built my
confidence and my self-esteem
and whatever's going to happen i'm going
to make something work unfortunately for
me
right place right time i was the first
guy and here was the moment because you
never know when that moment happens
which is why when i when i speak and
talk to people
you always have to keep that uniform on
because you never know when the coach is
going to say
hey evan get in the game
and if you're not ready that's the
moment that's the door open
that's when you have that shot to go in
there and do what it is whatever it is
you want
and here i was i was training i was
exercising
doing every good muscle head does you
know i was bouncing in a bar at night
i was working out in the morning and
catching rays
during the day and i was living in
studio city california
right where all the studios were and
this actress had come over to me
who i had seen a bunch of times and she
said hey you know can i ask you a
question
i said sure she says i've got
i've got a commercial i've got to do in
about six weeks i got to wear a bikini
remember this is 1979. jane fonda had
just come on the scene
with the high impact aerobic classes and
i was a bodybuilder
she said could you come up with a
workout for me
to to get in shape for this commercial
now evan and everybody were listening
i i was looking at this gala she was
great looking she looked terrific and i
immediately said you know what it's not
about how she feel
how she looks mentally psychologically
she was going to be in front of people
and she wanted to just feel
better about herself so i said yeah i
could come up with a workout and she
says well listen
i like you but i don't want to look like
you and i said no
no no i'll i'll come up with something
and what i did
i started thinking about what i was
going to do and she said well how much
is this going to cost
and i go i don't know give me gas money
for my 1977
white camaro with jake 77 on the license
plate
as an entrepreneur you always have to
keep a very low profile right you know
right and she said could you come to my
boyfriend's house and do the workout bed
gave me an address in beverly hills
i said no problem gotten my 77 white
camaro
off to beverly hills i improvised a
workout in my mind
using a broomstick a towel right towel
resistance training
if i were to give you evan a towel to
hold and i want to pull down on the
towel and say let's do some bicep curls
as opposed to giving you two 25-pound
dumbbells i could pull down on the towel
and give you
more resistance but psychologically it's
a bath towel
right and i made the workout fun a 30
minute workout
she i felt an a type personality
and i used a broomstick a towel a chair
and two cans of mama's tomato paste
seriously simple went to a boyfriend's
house knocked on the door
beverly hills if you weren't on the
cover of muscle had digest i don't know
who you were
guy answers the door turns out to be
francis ford
coppola wow and i just looked and i
thought wow hey
this guy could use a workout too and
it was wait you didn't know where he was
i didn't know no but i didn't know who
he was
i'm a bodybuilder you know if you're not
if you're not
on the cover of muscle and fitness i
didn't know who you were
so i started working this working with
these people
and they were really digging it they
started going to parties and people
started saying you look great
what are you doing this guy jake comes
to the house he's got a broomstick a
towel and a chair he's pretty funny
you know he eats too much because they
had a great refrigerator
and i got to tell you i had no dough
back then and they had a great fridge so
i would sit down and eat and talk to
them afterwards
and now one thing what happened was this
really simple
once again life's about moments
people started saying how do i get a
hold of this guy
well this was back in the day when there
was no uh cell phones
right you had to list your telephone
number in a phone book
i never did that i went from upstate new
york to l.a
i'm 19 years old now and
one thing about hollywood is if you're
good and people want to get a hold of
you and they can't
they seem to want you more and it became
this mystique
of who is this guy get him
and i'm getting phone calls now on my
little answering machine
in studio city in my one bedroom
apartment from steven spielberg harrison
ford
priscilla presley bent midler warren
beatty
i mean the the heads of all the studios
everybody was anybody and i i learned
the greatest
lesson and the greatest teachings of all
time
these people are no different than us no
different
the only difference is they had a dream
and they never quit on their dream
and never took no for an answer and you
know if
that's what gave me all the incentive in
the world to say to myself you know what
i might never direct et2
but i'm going to have my own success in
life
and i was able to parlay that famous by
association
into videos and books and television
shows and all of a sudden here i was in
this
magnificent time in the 80s in this
incredible place
called hollywood in this great country
called america
and it's the world let you be what you
make them believe you are
and ted turner is the guy that gave me
my start on television he saw an article
on me in people magazine
true story he calls oh by the way i
moved to westwood
now right so now i'm kind of moving on
up
i'm in westwood it's 1981 and i get a
phone call
from this guy ted turner who i call him
back
he says he has this new cable news
network
a global news network now by the way
westwood at the time
didn't have cable so i had no idea what
this guy was talking about
now just give you a case in point i'm
training all these big stars
and they're casting me in movies so john
landis is putting me and into the night
with jeff goldblum and michelle pfeiffer
right i mean i mean i'm in tough guys
with bert lancaster and kurt douglas
i'm this guy from brooklyn man i i never
took an acting lesson in my life no
no don't say anything about that i play
me
that's what i do that's all i know and i
was having the greatest
time of my life and which is what i do
every single day
and that's the thing that i talk to my
kids about too and for everybody
who has a passion it's never it's never
been to me about work
i don't think i've ever worked a day in
my life because i love
what i do i know you hear about this and
you talk to a lot of people
it truly has to be in your body
every day seven days a week 24 7.
you always have to make room which is
important which becomes the fabric of
who you
are because i talk about you being a
brand
and everyone needs to think and
understand that but for me
family has always come first my wife
my children first number one and anyone
i do business with
if anyone ever says anything like hey
jake i gotta take my son to school
or it hasn't or i have to take my
daughter to soccer practice
don't even say a word go take care of it
we'll talk later
there's plenty of time and plenty of
room and plenty of moments for
everybody to succeed and that's been the
way
i've always done my life one of the
things that i've
loved about your story is the longevity
and how you are still doing new things
you know one of my fears is being the
aging rock star you know i've been doing
youtube for 11 years and helping
entrepreneurs for 20
and i always got a little fearful of the
of the rock stars who then
you know like keep playing the hits from
30 years ago as opposed to coming up
with new stuff
and you're you're always doing new stuff
like if you go to
you go to jake's website you're going to
see all sorts of different playlists to
work out too
yeah just launch don't quit i see the
sign behind you there which is a line of
nutritional
shakes he's got some he's got there
there it is
we'll talk about it we'll talk about
this in a second but listen how about
opening up your fridge in the morning
and seeing those two words
don't quit every morning okay and we'll
talk about that in a second but you know
what though
it's it's not about even reinvention
it's about
you know my life revolves around hope
health and family everything that i've
done
everything that i've created so when ted
gave me my start doing the fitness break
on cable news network
i was able to parlay that into
television shows uh i had a body by jake
show and first run syndication
then espn i got into the infomercial
space
home shopping uh i did books and videos
um i did the first original video
soundtrack to an exercise video in 1983
right because i was learning because i
was hanging
with all these creative minds in
hollywood and the best of the best
and it was like why not what's the worst
that happens the worst that happens is
it doesn't work
and by the way i've succeeded a lot and
i failed a lot and i know
all entrepreneurs talk the same way if
you're not pushing hard enough
uh you you have to fail you just have to
you
trip up that's what you do you got to
keep pushing that's what keeps your
heart racing
i'm not a guy that likes to drive cars
fast
i have fast cars i don't drive them fast
i don't like to go skiing off of high
mountains you know
i like playing stickball bowling you
know uh ping-pong
i love that stuff where i get my
adrenaline rush where i love the action
is in creation is it is in creating
something that wasn't there before
to doing something now whether it was
the first
linear fitness television network called
fit tv
which i launched in 1993 uh which was a
24-hour fitness television network if
you remember it
uh it was great i had an opportunity i
sold it to rupert murdoch in 1998.
and then launched exercise tv the first
on-demand
fitness television network and it was
just success breeds success and as an
entrepreneur
i learned early evan i know what i know
and the stuff that you don't know
you want to surround yourself with
really good people or else
you end up a legend in your own shower
[Laughter]
what what what do you think somebody you
started this industry
basically uh you've seen so many people
come and go
so many of your contemporaries who also
built big names now
you know just kind of living at home and
not doing
but you're still doing it new stuff like
people
may know you just for your shakes and
now you know the whole history right
because it's like it's the new version
of jake
why do you think you've lasted so long
and still keep pushing
when so many of your content most of
your contemporaries
have stopped yeah well thank you for
that you know what it is it's it's the
energy and the action
and i'm hey listen i'm 62. i feel like
i'm 21.
i i train every morning i'm up at 3 45
in the morning i'm in the gym i do my 42
minute workout
my mind i do a 42 minute workout that is
both
mind and body where i visualize with
every repetition
i visualize everything that i have to
accomplish
during this day so i've i've already not
played through what this interview was
but
i thought in my mind of how this was
going to go where i was going what's up
next
i was a little late coming to you
because we had two more you know early
and
we thought someone had told me this was
uh east coast time or pacific time
so i said evan's got to go so we had to
jump but
it's about just creating
and i love to create and and to do it in
a way and and this is interesting too
because
we all have to give back everybody it's
important
i'm a i i love success but i'm
i'm a bad taker i'm a better giver and
the thing that i've been doing
for the last 15 years i put fitness
centers in elementary and middle schools
around this great country of ours um i
started as chair of the fitness council
in california here with arnold
when he was governor and then with jerry
brown and the last
this is my ninth year as chair of the
national foundation for governor's
fitness councils
where each year i choose four states uh
pick up the phone and call governors
cold
i have three brand new 100 000 don't
quit fitness centers
uh and i call governors and it's a gift
it isn't a grant it's a gift i i explain
to the governors it's
this is think of it as when you go to
your grandma's house
and your grandma gives you a toy or a
gift it's yours
right grants are they're all tied up
with stuff and
my feeling is there was a great article
on me it was in the wall street journal
it said
jake is like santa claus except with a
33-inch waist and i said well 34 but
i'll take the 33.
[Laughter]
and he's from new york 100 man i love it
man listen i know i know we're
we're kind of getting to the end of this
i want to talk quickly about don't quit
your new line
tell us what it is tell us where to get
it well first of all
this is it right here well guys this is
really important
you know i would do what i've been doing
for a long long time i had an
opportunity
you know i was never a supplement taker
never a vitamin taker
you know and as we age you you need your
nutrients
uh there's this category called adult
nutrition man
and uh there there are a couple of
brands in there right now
that if you look at the ingredient panel
on them quite frankly man they're
chemical based
and they taste crummy and it's look
my my mom is not doing so great she's in
a nursing home now they try to feed her
this stuff
and a lot of people get fed this really
crummy stuff people over the age of 50
especially right now during this
pandemic need to be need to be mindful
of their health
right and what they're putting in their
body nutrition is so important
i wanted to create a product right like
i said earlier too
and i and i say it's everybody the world
didn't need another nutrition shake
you know it just needed the best one and
i thought that the way to do it let's do
it with a clean label
26 vitamins and minerals no soy no corn
no wheat right no no
added all that other stuff man
artificial sweetness
gluten free kosher oh by the way it
tastes delicious
chocolate vanilla chai tea and orangical
now we have a max version which is 30
grams of protein and one gram of sugar
right but as you age too you know a lot
of people need to keep the weight on
even younger kids want to bulk up a
little bit
this is it here it is don't quit
this is our original flavors and as i
said to you in a fun way
keeping this when you open the fridge in
the morning and you see the words don't
quit
how motivational inspiring is that the
words
i trademarked in 1981 true story
i was cut from my eighth grade
basketball team in the early 70s
and it was devastating and a friend gave
me a poem
called don't quit at 14 i wasn't a poet
i didn't you know i was like
what do you give me a poem again and i
started to read it every night
every single night evan every single
night and it became a bible verse to me
and in 1981 i trademarked those words i
kept the word sacred
i i fought off all the big companies and
i thought that quite honestly
that i would end up passing the the word
the trademark on to my children
because there was nothing that i wanted
that i believed in so
now i had books that were called don't
quit and things but not a product
and everything that i have my name on
it's my company i owe now i partnered
with cura dr pepper
on don't quit and a great company called
la libations
uh incredible groups but i wanted to
make sure that if i was going to do this
the product needed to be awesome now the
sugar in here is pure cane sugar so on
our original formula there is 14 grams
of sugar
but it's less than the competition in
this adult nutrition category
as i said if you want less sugar on max
version and chocolate or vanilla
just go to don't quit.com don't quit.com
super simple
bang bang bang bang bang there it is
there it is
let me get it right there oh wait and
there's my mug too right now
there you go so so when you see it in
supermarkets
uh it's it's uh it's really exciting the
reviews have been great
online we've already sold out a
chocolate max
so get on there early tell us what
you're thinking about
and uh and this poem which is important
and
i think we're running out of time i
don't know the exact time but i just
want to end to let everybody know
this poem is super special it's called
don't quit as i said i trademark those
words don't quit
i didn't i didn't author the poem in the
late 1800s
but it really goes like this when things
go wrong as they sometimes will when the
road you're trudging
seems all uphill when the funds are
alone the debts are high
and you want to smile but you have to
sigh when care is pressing you down a
bit
rest if you must but don't you quit life
is queer with its twists and turns
as every one of us sometimes learn and
many have failed you turn about when he
might have won had he stuck it out
don't give up though the pace seems slow
you may succeed with another blow
stick to the fight when your hardest hit
it's when things seem worse
that you must not quit don't quit
guys go check it out don't quit.com when
you open your fridge you have one that
says don't quit
and then and then you tilt the other one
sideways to see jake's face
there we go push you did not quit there
we go
thank you man thank you for the time uh
i love that you've lost this company and
um appreciate the words of wisdom today
hey brother keep on keeping on baby
don't quit much love thank you jake
okay see you if you want to change your
life for free in 30 days check the link
right here below me
or if you want to see the one-on-one i
did with wim the iceman hoff
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy them continue to
believe
and i'll see you there